hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here to beat the only Slenderman
shadow map that has kicked my ass
repeatedly I've beaten all of these ones
besides carnival bobbing all of these
ones except for prison so I'm here to
reenact some vengeance and destroy I
hope the lads to say ah I'm naturally
not sure this is the first time I've
ever visited I'm one of the old maps
that he remade so this will be the woo
oh look at that look at that lens flare
on the Unity engine so pretty okay so if
the layout is exactly the same I should
be fine
a peg not here that's okay I remember
where the page is are because you kicked
my ass ten bajillion times to the point
where I know this game or this
particular map backwards and forwards
Hey look he took dizzy he's always
watching how about that ain't that cool
he's always watching okay so actually
from what I remember this strategies
that I've read over and over and over
and over again demanded that you start
running like right away but apparently
the running mechanic isn't as good this
time around so and you go through here
looking in the flippity slinks and the
slew bit of glow buddies oh look at that
Oh what do you know it's another page
not in the sinks this time alright
whatever
I'm gonna read this into the ground and
I'm gonna rub Lenny's face in the mud
I'm gonna call him bad names I'm gonna
sleep with his mother your army say I'm
gonna bang your mom yeah that was shown
okay I crap I don't remember which way
to go now I think yeah there we go yep I
know it it's rude to stare it's pretty
austere if I want to
now now Slendy no need to be upset was
that oh those pipe no need to be upset
I'm here to help you yeah that's right
I'm here to help you okay I think the
app I know it I know it I would have
missed this one if I hadn't come over
here good thing I'm so smart
good dang good thing I'm so smart okay
also from what I learned in my
experience with Carnival wow what did
they just do to myself I am likely going
to need to look at him when he's around
me because because that seems to Lachman
place it's kind of a leftover a lot of
strategies set to beat him seem to be a
leftover from no escape a screw you I'm
gonna escape so hard I'm gonna escape so
good I tell ya
hey buddy how's it going what you gonna
do a way over there huh a whole lot of
nothing that's right get out of here
alright so um aha no one survives all
yeah right
hey whoa whoa hey you stay over there
okay now I'm gonna go this way and I'm
gonna get the eff out of here
okay so if I carry on oh crap I think I
just made a wrong turn
oh crap because there's two left and
I've never gotten to the eighth one
before so I'm not exactly sure where it
is
see ya this way ah balls balls balls
where is it it's in here ah where is it
where is it where is it where is it it's
supposed to be in here it was well there
it is okay I'm good I'm good I'm good
so let's go let's go let's go let's go
come on
aha sky be calm calm cool and collected
calm cool and collected it's this way
calm cool and collected calm cool and
collected
calm cool collected calm cool collected
Gaga spread [ __ ] off ah [ __ ] you prison
[ __ ] are you no-good son of a [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah O'Doyle rules ah mmm
yeah about damn time fer try cuz I know
it god it's frickin impossible before
okay alright I was a quick little video
just showing that I am good at this game
kinda guy did so all right now the only
one left is Carnaval cuz I'm not even
I'm not going anywhere near the
Christmas special again screw that so
the only one left on my list to beat
I've beaten them all except for Carnaval
alright so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
Oh